With only a couple of months to go until the
film's release, Disney tantalized Star Wars
fans with a new trailer for the latest chapter
in the Skywalker saga — Star Wars: The Last
Jedi.
According to director Rian Johnson, fans who
want to go in completely clean might actually
want to skip watching the trailer.
But if potential spoilers hold no power over
you, let's take a look at what you might've
missed in The Last Jedi's new trailer.
Luke's biggest fear
The trailer picks up where The Force Awakens
left off — on the planet Ahch-To, as Rey
hands Luke the lightsaber that was once wielded
by his father, Darth Vader.
We then see Rey training with the weapon as
Luke looks on, and it soon becomes clear just
how innately talented she is.
Skywalker looks positively shocked as the
ground cracks open while Rey meditates, and
it's clear he's having flashbacks to what
happened with his last protégé — his nephew
Ben Solo, who now serves Supreme Leader Snoke
under the name Kylo Ren.
"I've seen this raw strength only once before."
It's then that Luke reveals he's actually
afraid of Rey's talents, just as we get a
more detailed look at the aftermath of the
attack on Luke's Jedi Temple by Kylo and the
Knights of Ren.
He's clearly reluctant to train her, lest
she turn to the dark side.
Rey's journey
While it's clear that Rey spends some time
with Luke on Ahch-To, she's not going to always
be on the water's edge.
She's also shown approaching what looks like
a burned tree trunk in a rocky landscape,
and looking down at a book inside Luke's Force-sensitive
treehouse.
In the previous teaser, she was browsing what
many believe is the fabled Journal of the
Whills, which means Rey is about to get a
lesson in the origins of the Force and the
Jedi Order from her new teacher.
Later, we see a drenched Luke looking up and
saying, "this is not going to go the way you
think."
Considering we also see Rey diving under the
water near what looks like a fanged sea monster,
it might go exactly like we think it will
— that shot directly aligns with rumors
that the native Porgs of Ahch-To will demand
that Rey slay a fearsome sea monster in order
to stay on the planet.
Kylo's moment of truth
You may have noticed the space battle shots
featuring a new version of the classic TIE
fighter.
This is Kylo Ren's personal craft, and it's
called the TIE Silencer.
It's supposed to be sort of like the original
trilogy's TIE interceptor and comes equipped
with laser cannons and missile launchers.
In this battle sequence, it appears that Kylo
Ren is setting his sights on a Mon Calamari
star cruiser.
And since General Leia Organa is shown sitting
down on the bridge, the implication of the
cutaways between Leia's face and her son's
are clear: each knows the other is there,
and Ben has the opportunity to deal a gigantic
blow to the Resistance by destroying the ship
and — ending the life of his mother.
Now for the big question — will he or won't
he pull the trigger?
Finn's weapon
In one major spoiler given away by the trailer,
we see that Finn has clearly recovered from
the wounds he sustained during The Force Awakens,
and is back in fighting shape for a duel against
Captain Phasma.
Phasma wields a Force pike, while Finn is
carrying a riot-control baton much like the
one previously carried by the stormtrooper
he fought during the battle on Takodana in
The Force Awakens.
"Traitor!"
We also couldn't help but notice Finn's First
Order officer's uniform in the following scene
as he walks somewhere, escorted by stormtroopers.
In case you missed it, he and new character
Rose don those uniforms in behind-the-scenes
footage that's made its way online.
So since the background behind Finn and Phasma
in their duel looks a lot like the destroyed
remnants of the First Order, this duel might
possibly take place after an secret infiltration
and sabotage mission by Finn and Rose.
New creatures
In addition to the previously mentioned Porgs,
The Last Jedi is set to introduce a whole
bunch of new additions to the Star Wars universe.
While we didn't see them in the trailer, Entertainment
Weekly broke the news in August 2017 that
Ahch-To's residents include a group of nun-like
creatures known only as the Caretakers.
But the trailer did feature one exciting shot
of another new species: the crystalline fox-like
animals which reside on the mineral world
of Crait.
The Battle of Crait
It seems clear from the new trailer — and
all of the other footage released thus far
— that the land-battle on Crait will play
a major role in The Last Jedi.
The new trailer gives us our first good look
at the massive firepower that the First Order
will bring to bear against the Resistance
on the surface of the planet.
Those In place of the regular old Imperial
walkers are the new and improved AT-M6 walkers.
One can only hope that these machines are
just as susceptible to proton bombs, harpoons,
and tow cables as their older cousins — or
the Resistance may really be in some trouble.
Snoke's identity
The trailer doesn't actually give away Snoke's
identity — but it does reveal a big clue.
Leading up to the final moments of the trailer,
we hear Snoke apparently telling Rey she needs
to "fulfill your destiny," and it looks like
he's using his powers to torture her.
This could also mean that Snoke's voiceover
from the beginning of the trailer where he
talks about someone's "raw untamed power"
could be directed at Rey — and not Kylo
Ren.
"Let the past die."
Instead of a 30-foot-tall hologram like in
The Force Awakens, this is Snoke in the flesh
— and his flesh appears to be distinctly
humanoid.
That seems to blow the "Snoke is Darth Plagueis"
theory out of the water, since he was an alien,
and it also apparently debunks the "Snoke
is Grand Moff Tarkin" theory, since Snoke
seems able to use the Force, while Tarkin
couldn't.
As for how he got ahold of Rey to begin with,
well, consider the rumors that Kylo will attack
Luke and Rey on Ahch-To, and it seems possible
that Kylo ends up abducting Rey from the planet
and taking her back to his master.
The Millennium Falcon soars again
In a couple of short clips from the new The
Last Jedi trailer, we see the Millennium Falcon
back in action, diving and twisting through
what appears to be an underground labyrinth.
Based on the red crystals we can see, it seems
likely that this dogfight happens in a cave
somewhere on Crait.
And notice how the Porg and Chewbacca are
shown together on the ship, but we don't see
who's in the pilot seat?
If Kylo abducts Rey, this could spur Luke
— who's not such a bad pilot himself — to
join Chewie and return to his sister Leia
to help her take on the First Order.
Poe's fire
In our first glimpse of Poe Dameron from the
trailer, he's aboard what appears to be some
sort of Mon Calamari lifeboat, which could
point to the starcruiser we saw previously
getting hit, and promises to:
"Burn the First Order down."
He hops in his X-Wing — which appears to
have been retrofitted with some sort of afterburner
— as he dives and spins in an attack run
on the First Order Dreadnought looming above
Crait.
Frenemies
Last but not least, there's that seemingly...friendly
exchange between Rey and Kylo.
This may be some editing misdirection, but
it sure looks like Rey is telling Kylo she
needs some advice.
This clip of Rey could come from when she
tries to persuade Luke to train her.
But the clip of Kylo Ren is more elusive — he
has his scar, so it can't be a flashback to
when he destroyed Luke's temple.
Additionally, he's no longer wearing the bandage
we've seen in earlier clips.
This could suggest that the clip comes from
near the end of the movie.
But who could Kylo be extending his hand to?
It's a clip that neatly echoes the visuals
of the scene between Han and his son.
So could Kylo be possibly accepting redemption
from the hands of his mother — or his uncle?
Or is it another double cross?
Thankfully, we won't have to wait much longer
to find out.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!